cette norme
les chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
pendant neuf ans va avoir droit
je viens de rompre avec dieu
je n'aime plus
en amour on est toujours 2 1 qui
s'emmerdent et hacker malheureux
depuis quelques temps de dieu me semble
est malheureux
alors j'ai rompu
j'ai bu qui a dit en amour on est
toujours 2 qui s'emmerdent est inquiet
malheureux jeux plus si lucien guitry ou
sacha distel
je sais que c'est un coureur cycliste
mais joli bouquet
bref j'ai rompu
lent et sournois le feu de la rupture
couvait depuis longtemps entre dieu et
moi
j'ai tout fait pour l'étouffer mais j'ai
tout fait
je sentais sans cesse la présence
étouffante justement de dieu au dessus
de moi comme un vieux paparazzi
collaborateurs à je suis partout il
était perpétuellement lââm observé
surgissant dans ma vie à n'importe
quelle heure du jour ou de la nuit toc
toc celle laitiers dont ces dieux allège
tolérer plus longtemps de dieu ce que je
supportais si mal du kgb
et puis je m'entendais pas très bien
avec sa famille
je trouvais surtout que le fils avait
mauvais genre je ne pense pas bégueule
mais ce côté m'as tu vu sur ma jolie
croit nommé pampers absorbant j'ai
toujours pensé que ça avait desservi le
prestige de l'église et contribué pour
une large part à l'abandon de l'habit
sacerdotal au profit de la soutane race
bonbons chez les prêtres intégristes
bisexuels d'obédience oecuménique ses
pointes en
moins omniprésent mais d'une suffisance
dans ses envolées surprise le dernier du
trio le saint-esprit m'horripile et
presqu'autant cette façon de vous tomber
dessus à l'improviste en plein gueuleton
de pentecôte chez mon beau frère quelle
grossièreté
coucou coucou l oapi taxpayers laisse
bien descendu
de grâce ma colombe fou nous la paix
j'ai posté hier hier soir ma lettre de
rupture je voulais lui
paris le [ __ ] sur [ __ ] oui j'étais tout seul
cher dieu
ne m'attends pas dimanche je ne viendrai
pas je ne viendrai plus jamais le
dimanche ni les autres jours ni les
autres nuits
dieu mon grand montrait grand montrer
aux je ne t'aime plus
ce qu'il m'en coûte de te faire cet aveu
toi seul le sait
mais tu dois bien admettre que nous ne
pouvons plus continuer ainsi à nous
faire du mal toi mais espérant en vain
et moi ni croyant plus
je sais j'ai tous les torts depuis le
début de notre liaison j'ai été trompé
cent fois en cent lieues de bassesse
peuple et de [ __ ] en cuir et daim
torche abl marin rouge qui me collait à
leur sueur en salissant ton nom
à la source du mal j'ai bu les alcools
effroyable et aspirer à gueule ouverte
les volutes interdite des paradis où tu
n'es pas mon dieu mon dieu tu te
souviens de ce soir de mai brûlant où
nous regardions ensemble soleil en juin
mourir doucement sur la loire j'étais
bouleversé par tant de beauté tranquille
et toi toi tu m'a cru plus près de toi
mon dieu plus près de toi que jamais
alors même que dévoré par un désir
éperdu de mort païenne je jouissais
gravement dans les bras même du diable
dieu tout est fini entre nous
pourtant je t'ai aimé dès le premier
jour rappelle toi
je ne vais pas 13 ans était dans ta
maison il y avait de l'or troubles aux
vitraux et cette musique de fer profonde
et la magie de ce parfum d'orient qui
n'appartient qu'à toi je me suis
agenouillé tu es venu mon dieu je t'ai
reçu tout entier
dieu fond dans la bouche pas dans la
main
tu es entré en moi et j'ai pleuré ce
sont des choses qui marque une vie
elles sont ineffaçables
mais aujourd'hui mon dieu je ne t'aime
plus je t'en prie oublie moi je suis
grain de sable et d'autres hommes
t'aimerons que tu sauras aimé aux quatre
coins du monde de beyrouth à moscou et
de gdansk à santiago à dieu pardonne moi
mais offense mais laisse-moi succomber à
la tentation donne moi aujourd'hui mon
péché quotidien et des livres au mois du
bien ainsi soit il
veuillez croire moi pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
by the way moche qui disent qu'en
feinberg
taratata
la dalle est là
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non